Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
bienvenidos una vez más a este espacio
donde defendemos las artes y la cultura
en todas sus formas un gusto estar en
sintonía con ustedes desde nuestros
estudios en París y hoy quisiéramos
presentarles a un artista que vive y
trabaja en la capital francesa pero que
pone algo de su feminidad y de su
trópico natal en cada obra que sale de
sus manos Ella es la colombiana
Estefanía Tejada autora de retratos
feministas coloridos y potentes
Estefanía Muchísimas gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en Carrusel de las
artes Muchas gracias por la invitación
Estefanía y tú vienes de tuluá en el en
el Valle del cauca en Colombia Has
vivido en México en Barcelona y ahora
trabajas aquí en París y también has
pasado por diferentes medios la moda el
diseño el dibujo ahora estás haciendo
pintura digital y en óleo y quisiera
preguntarte sobre una obra en particular
que has desarrollado en los últimos años
que son
retratos feministas y muy coloridos
háblanos específicamente de esa parte de
tu de Tu arte Pues básicamente mi obra
está completamente influenciada por mi
experiencia como mujer latina en los
diferentes lugares en los que he vivido
yo estudio la evolución del espíritu
femenino a través de mis experiencias
obviamente como mujer latina Todos hemos
pasado por situaciones difíciles
momentos difíciles pero cómo utilizas
las enseñanzas y los aprendizajes y
transformas esos momentos para ayudar
también a otras personas y es algo que
he logrado mucho conmigo obra que me
tomó por sorpresa porque cuando yo
transformo estas situaciones a veces
situaciones dolorosas otras personas
otras mujeres empezaron también a
conectar entonces me empezaban a
escribir mensajes diciéndome me encanta
tu obra me conecto demasiado la
mirada de las mujeres es sumamente
fuerte sumamente Poderosa
Y eso causó gran impacto en mí me ayudó
también como a desarrollar y a
evolucionar cada vez más mi obra y ahora
para describir un poco esos retratos Son
son retratos a veces en formatos
bastante grandes de mujeres la mujer
tiene una un lugar central y Está
rodeada muchas veces de una vegetación
muy exuberante puede ser la selva puede
ser flores pueden ser las orquídeas que
son tan importantes en colombianos
háblanos un poco de esa mezcla de tanto
la mujer rodeada de esa fuerza que
también lleva la naturaleza para mí hay
una conexión demasiado grande entre lo
que es ser mujer y en la madre tierra o
sea para mí la madre tierra es la
primera madre que tenemos es el lugar de
donde venimos son nuestros orígenes y
creciendo en un lugar como tuluá que
pues es una ciudad bastante pequeña pero
Está rodeada de naturaleza de palmeras
por ejemplo la gente cuando ve las obras
vete verde intenso y es exactamente lo
que yo veo en casa o sea cuando visitó a
mis es cuando voy a mi tierra Esos son
los tonos es lo que me rodea es mi hogar
entonces para mí la naturaleza vive
dentro de mí entonces puedo estar en
París puedo estar en Barcelona pero
o sea toda esta flora fauna yo la siento
en mí entonces trato de compartir con
otras personas porque creo que es
importante que entendamos Que para que
el mundo evolucione no es necesario
destruir lo que ya tenemos no es
necesario destruir los orígenes
tenemos que aprender a convivir
obviamente tiene que haber una evolución
pero de qué forma unimos ambas cosas
dentro del Progreso como nuestros
orígenes para que haya una evolución en
conjunto y ahora y hablando de esa
figura central que es la mujer en tus
retratos también hay mucha diversidad
hay mujeres mestizas hay mujeres
afrodescendientes hay mujeres indígenas
háblanos un poco era importante para ti
esa diversidad en tus obras es sumamente
importante especialmente porque en
Colombia obviamente ya ha cambiado un
poco pero
existían momentos en los que no sé
resaltaba esta diversidad y en algunos
casos por ejemplo editoriales no sé era
las fiestas del Pacífico pero para
representar eso utilizaron una persona
Blanca vestida con obviamente los
atuendos de las mujeres del Pacífico y
cuando le cuando le presentas Le enseñas
como a personas por ejemplo en Europa en
Estados Unidos que tenemos
afrodescendientes que tenemos personas
blancas la gente dice cómo pero pensé
que solamente era mestizos que solo o
sea como que ya hay un arquetipo un
argentino un poco Jack cliché pero la
verdad es que somos un país sumamente
diverso no solamente en Colombia pero
también en los países vecinos Entonces
se me hace súper importante Resaltar
esto y por otra parte para mí la mujer
es sumamente importante uno Yo soy mujer
y estuve siempre rodeada de mujeres Mi
madre es una mujer sumamente fuerte una
mujer poderosa O sea la matriarca de la
casa a la cual O sea ya exige respeto y
literal ella y todo el mundo como que se
pone en su sitio y creciendo también
me enseña un poco como en las
comunidades indígenas que se unen todas
las mujeres para criar a los hijos y yo
tuve eso de una u otra forma esa
solidaridad Entonces no solamente es tu
mamá pero tus abuelas que tienen la
misma autoridad que tu mamá tus tías las
amigas de mi mamá o sea siempre alguien
aportó algo aportó una enseñanza aportó
un apoyo aportó una visión Entonces al
final todas las mujeres se reúnen para
crear un nuevo futuro para las para las
generaciones que vienen cuando se habla
de pintura y cuando se habla de retratos
en la historia de la de la pintura
siempre ha habido artistas que tienen
Musas tú tienes Musas en Colombia
recientemente tengo una quema Ella es
una modelo colombiana pero ahorita está
en Londres
y ella tiene un poco como estas raíces
indígenas y la vez visualmente pero para
mí una indígena contemporánea y lo que
me encanta de ella lo que realmente
conecta conmigo es su sensibilidad su
conexión con las emociones
que no tiene miedo de ser ella y
honestamente cuando la veo físicamente
obviamente en conjunto con quien es ella
como como ser me inspira completamente
es como una necesidad de pintarla y
ahora hablamos de la actitud que tienen
Estas mujeres en tus en tus retratos
casi siempre tienen una actitud muy
imponente muy fuerte muy segura incluso
a veces creo que no hay ninguna que
sonríe es una es una solemnidad una una
pose solemne
pues la parte no sonreír viene mucho de
mi infancia porque siempre la sociedad o
sea le dice a la mujer sonríe porque
porque no estás alegre pero para mí no
es necesario sonreír para ser feliz y
para mí como el aspecto lo más
importante como de la cara de los
rostros de las mujeres que pinto son los
ojos para mí los ojos te dicen
absolutamente todo sobre una persona la
historia las diferentes las diferentes
enseñanzas las diferentes situaciones
por las que ha pasado ves dolor en los
ojos ves cansancio ves todas las vías
que una persona ha tenido que vivir
entonces esa parte se me hace súper
importante
pero sí en general Es como eso es la
conexión del ser y
el poder o sea para mí una mujer es
sumamente poderosa nuevamente la
conexión que tenemos como seres
creadores porque pues sin la mujer No
hay vida tampoco
y esta conexión que tenemos con la
naturaleza entonces
se me hace importante como unir a las
dos y Mostrar el poder de las dos de
ambas partes unidas y ahora Yo lo decía
al principio de nuestro programa tú
trabajas en digital pero también
trabajas el óleo cómo pasas de uno al
otro para ti es equivalente depende de
lo que te soliciten Cómo trabajas
depende cuando es mi práctica personal
hay una necesidad O sea no del pincel o
donde le dije el corazón no es una
necesidad del ser de crear y depende de
lo que quiera crear claramente Porque
por ejemplo la actividad en óleo es
mucho más física
es mucho más pesada tienes que estar
bien mentalmente o sea es todo tu ser
básicamente de cierta forma
sacrificándose para crear Esta obra
sacando todo lo que tiene y es un poco
lo mismo en digital pero es un proceso
no tan agresivo y obviamente también
trabajo por comisiones o cuando preparo
exhibiciones
pues ya determino Cuál de los dos
caminos toma justamente este año del
2022 estuviste en el año pasado en 2022
estuviste haciendo una exposición aquí
en París pero también hace sobras para
marcas que pueden ser de
artículos de lujo artículos deportivos
tecnología cuéntanos ese otro otro
dominio que no es el los museos sino
otro lugar de exposición y de presentar
Tu arte que son esas pedidos que te
hacen marcas específicas Pues siento que
hoy en día más y más las marcas ven el
potencial en el arte y usualmente son
colaboraciones que hacemos que pueden
ser a través de moda en este caso puedo
hacer las ilustraciones de una campaña
por ejemplo O podría ser los estampados
de una prenda entonces ahí ya se unen
dos visiones para crear un concepto
completamente nuevo
en otros casos colaborado por ejemplo
con Marie Claire que está muy la revista
muy alineados maricle Francia muy
alineados con el poder de la mujer con
por ejemplo temas obviamente mucho más
abiertos con la necesidad de tener o no
hijos entonces está bastante conectado
con quien soy como persona entonces creo
que lo importante Ahí es identificar
Quién es cuál es el cliente que te puede
generar una colaboración en donde
realmente haya una Unión y quiero saber
que colaboraste también con el México
que fue una colaboración que te gustó
mucho porque
con el México Pues he colaborado varias
veces con
Fernanda
en este caso la última colaboración que
hicimos fue sobre por ejemplo
el pero No necesariamente es que no es
con él Ah perdón No sé cuál era la que
te refieres Ah yo bien tu biografía el
México y vi la portada Ah okay pero no
no me no me gustó Ah perdón okay está
bien bueno es que o sea por ejemplo lo
que hice con él fue
en el 2020 creo que fue para el mes de
Pride e hicimos unos retratos por
ejemplo de Jean Paul Gutiérrez entonces
obviamente para México esto es un tema
bastante Pues que todavía están
trabajando en ello pero poder retratar
como personas Que obviamente están
abiertas a quienes son se me hace
sumamente importante obviamente para
cambiar la conversación se me hace
importante que hablemos sobre el tema
que haya esta apertura y la última
colaboración que hicimos fue más como
hacía el placer femenino
te parece que esos temas están hoy en
día sobre la mesa y que eso que tú
habías visto desde tuluá que querías
poner en tu arte es lo que hoy día está
sobre el tapete en todo el mundo
total creo que en esta parte se me hace
súper importante la imaginación del ser
arriesgarte y saber básicamente qué
quieres y simplemente soñar o sea se me
hace sumamente importante porque la
única persona que puede ver en lo que te
vas a convertir eres tú y saber que yo
era esa persona en tuluá que todas las
todas las noches cuando dormía soñaba
con todas las oportunidades que tengo
hoy en día es sumamente gratificante y
te enseña también sobre el poder de la
mujer o sea cómo manifiestas lo que
quieres y el poder que tienes también
para cambiar la percepción que mujeres
tienen sobre sí mismas ayudarlas a
hacerlas hacerles entender que ellas
también son poderosas que ellas también
pueden crear hacerles ver la belleza de
la de la diversidad de los diferentes
rasgos esto se me hace sumamente
gratificante Estefanía Y cómo cómo has
sentido esa recepción de tu obra aquí en
Europa porque Bueno hablamos de
sentimiento de mujer de fuerza de mujer
y no forzosamente una mujer europea
tiene el mismo camino recorrido que una
mujer latinoamericana Pero cómo cómo ha
sido la recepción de esas obras que tú
haces aquí en Europa lo han recibido
bastante lo han recibido bastante bien
Honestamente ha sido una muy buena
acogida
y han sido bastante abiertos a mi
concepto también Creo que porque es un
mundo nuevo para ellos exuberante
exótico total es completamente distinto
y es también volver a esta conexión con
lo terrenal con lo espiritual entonces
las oportunidades que han surgido en
París o desde que he estado aquí también
Obviamente con el Reino Unido en Estados
Unidos en China
realmente
pues han expandido y han generado un
crecimiento en mí en mi obra y en mi
trayectoria bueno nosotros no podemos
sino desearte todo el éxito del mundo
Gracias por haber estado con nosotros
Estefanía Tejada retratos
de mujeres de naturaleza de fuerza y de
la fuerza de la madre tierra Muchísimas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros y
a todos ustedes Muchísimas gracias por
su sintonía hasta la próxima
[Música]